good morning hank it's thursday today
we're going to learn how to make fairly
good roasted potatoes despite the
gnawing feeling that the universe and
everything in it is absolutely apathetic
to you this recipe comes from my digital
cookbook the new version of which is
available only during this year's
project for awesome at
projectforawesome.com donate okay so
some people cook because they love it or
because they have extremely
sophisticated palettes and find delight
in perfectly balanced flavor
combinations i cook because i am hungry
while we wash the potatoes it's worth
considering that the kinds of food you
crave are dictated partly by your cells
and partly by the bacterial cells inside
of your gut like studies have shown that
people with certain gut microbiomes are
more likely to crave refined
carbohydrates while people with other
microbiomes might crave other foods so
you should remember that when cooking
you're not just making food for you
you're also making food for the
trillions of microorganisms that
colonize you and influence your every
thought feeling and experience even
though they are not in the narrowest
sense you all right let's make some
potatoes you want enough potatoes that
they will sustain the sack of flesh that
contains your soul for several hours and
ideally you want these little red
potatoes which you then cut into sixths
or eighths if they're too big don't
overthink the size of your potato wedges
but also don't underthink it this is the
key not just for cooking but also for
most things spread those potatoes on a
greased baking pan oh no you forgot to
preheat the oven to 350 degrees do that
or 375 if you want to take a risk and
have fun now drizzle olive oil all over
the potatoes and then sprinkle them with
salt and pepper some people like to add
garlic salt here which is fine i'm not
gonna judge i mean we're making a meal
not a spaceship next wash your hands and
consider if you have any herbs rosemary
is ideal here thyme is also good oregano
i don't know maybe if you're feeling it
now sprinkle some herbs on top of those
potatoes and mix it all together don't
be afraid to get a little dirty there's
not enough joy in this world so take the
time to really feel a deep sense of
kinship with these potatoes these fellas
were in the ground not long ago growing
in the soft dirt of nebraska or idaho or
some place you've never visited except
to drive through all right that's enough
now put them in the oven for 15 minutes
while you wait read two paragraphs of a
new yorker piece about king tut but then
start wondering whether king tut died of
tuberculosis a question which can only
be answered by your phone where you
learn that it turns out he might have
died of a fractured femur anyway since
your phone is already out you might as
well check your email and then you know
what just one tick tock and now suddenly
the timer is beeping and literally where
did the time go alright now it's time to
flip the potatoes i like to do this by
hand because i don't have a lot of
adventure in my life and this really
gets the blood flowing but you can also
use a spatula while you're flipping let
a random tick tock play over and over
again because there's some weird comfort
in the loop of it in another human voice
in the room with you saying the same
thing over and over and over at this
point you'll want to think about how
incredibly weird it is to be a human
like you're a mammal eating the storage
organs of nightshade plants in order to
sustain your own departure from chemical
equilibrium while listening to a
repeating tick-tock don't think about
this too much though or else you'll
forget that the pan is still very hot
and not use appropriate protective mitts
now put the potatoes back in the oven
for another 15 minutes and then take
them out and debate whether they are
done if you're a risk-averse person like
me leave them a little undercooked but
if you want to peer out over the edge of
a great height then put them back in the
oven and try to time it perfectly so
that the potatoes are browned but not
burnt then pull them out probably a
couple minutes too late and let them
cool before enjoying hank the fundraiser
for the project for awesome is live now
you can get great perks at
projectforawesome.com donate the live
stream starts at noon tomorrow i will
see you then